I think we can agree that
democracy is a wonderful system
for people who are basically insane.
Dave Barry is the author of approximately eleventy billion books
and the recipient of exactly one Pulitzer Prize.
For four decades he wrote a weekly column
syndicated from his home base of the Miami Herald
and he is the author of the annual despairing hilarious Year in Review.
If you think that's tough you ought to try writing a humor column.
Barry's books form the basis for a short-lived show about his life,
Dave's World.
And his novel, Big Trouble, was made into a film
of the same name.
Next bullet goes through your head.
It's the story of a bunch of miscreants
who wind up inadvertently stealing a nuclear suitcase
and hijacking a plane due to their own incompetence.
The film was set to be released
inauspiciously on September 12, 2001.
What is this? Garbage disposal.
I sat down with Barry to talk about his new book,
Lessons From Lucy,
America's strategic helium reserve,
First of all, we need helium. The country needs—you can't have a country without helium.
I assume.
Yeah, probably.
So I would go to war for the helium, yeah.
The jokes he can't tell anymore,
and his perennial, vaguely libertarian campaign for the presidency.
I am also running for President of the United States.
Thank you.
We last spoke, you last spoke with Reason in 1994,
And you figure it's about time
You know, we didn't want to overexpose you—Twenty-five years have gone by—
We thought it was about time to bring you back to our viewers.
At the time you were running for president. Are you still running for president?
Well, yeah, I mean in the sense that—and I used to view it as sort of a joke,
but it's getting harder and harder to do.
Yeah. Well, I think that you will be officially
the 25th entrant into the 2020 field.
if you are running right now.
I think if right now we took a poll in Iowa,
I'd be ahead of Bill DeBlasio by quite a bit.
Not a little, a lot.
Yeah.
And that's only because he's the most obscure one whose name I can actually think of.
There are people far more obscure than Bill DeBlasio,
and I'd be ahead of them, too.
I think there might be a special hatred for Bill DeBlasio in Iowa,
so I think that was a good edge.
As there should be.
I was just in New York and and I can't, I didn't sense,
let me put it this way, this sense.
I would mention it occasionally to people he's running for.
and the, the feeling among New Yorkers,
you would think his base is not real positive.
Not a groundswell.
No.
But the Dave Barry campaign on the other hand
—is a juggernaut—is taking off.
What is your platform?
Well, the number one thing that really got me started,
and it's sort of a Reason related thing,
was low-flow toilets.
I was against them.
I was one of the first people against them,
and I'm still against them.
I think we still have them.
But I like to point out that we had
really great toilets in this country.
When I grew up, you probably did too, great toilets.
Make America's bathrooms great again.
We could suck down a mature sheep with our toilets and now
Now, you know look what we're dealing with.
So there's a point, kind of a bedrock principle.
That's my like the equivalent of Trump's wall.
Mine is like just toilets like we're taking away from us by regulators
Yeah is so it's a kind of a deregulation thing and then of course, I'm always up for accepting
Kim you know campaign contributions. That's a kind of a fundamental part of my campaign is is people giving money to it
How's that going?
Not so well at the moment, but I'm glad to have this opportunity to make yeah
Just do a little ice cream fund-raising I take venmo
I I think I'll have to ask my daughter how it works
But I would take it if if it were available
Good and I mean in general you have a long glorious history of using the federal government as a punchline
well, I've said this for many years if you
View the federal government as a form of entertainment. It's a lot easier to just cope with it mentally
So I vote when I write the you know quarterly check for my income taxes
I think that I'm getting a lot of a lot of value for that lately
I feel the federal government is just strictly as an entertainment entertainment medium. It's pretty good. It's pretty good
What do you say to people that are like?
You know Dave it's a it's all very well and good but like things are really serious now
Well, I will give a semi serious answer to that. I I
mean I'll give I'll give them that there are issues that they should be upset about and
issues, we're all upset about but I
Believe I had a lot of friends who when when Trump was elected president
Honestly fought and I don't know why they thought this but they thought they were gonna be in trouble with the police
For I don't know why and I would say to them if you know like the Coral Gables
Please find a time to come around to your house arrest you or something. Let me know
okay, I'll do anything I can just but there was kind of that level of
Concern so it's you know, that's insane
And I think those people have served figured that out at some point that it's it's um, you know, whatever's happening
It's happening in a much more macro level than that, but even there
You know
I always Liz will write my lecture that where I
Turn into old person for my kids like I grew up in the 60s when in this very city that we're in right now
Washington DC there were troops in the streets fires raging
Snipers on building the president was assassinated a couple years before then
His brother was assassinated in Martinique. There's last say there was less not to mention the war in Vietnam and the civil rights movement
Where it was?
Pretty clear that you know terrible things were happening in the South, you know
Oh, I don't I can't imagine you would look at all that and say that right now today things are worse. I just
Does that maybe a stupid old person I to take comfort in the fact that the entire late 60s appeared to be on fire
But I also didn't live through it. So maybe that's why you missed it. I missed all the bad times. Yeah, apparently, you know just
It is there's so much drama in people's minds now
You know Twitter fuelled drama about how everything is just horrible
And I'm just too old as fuck it I can only take like 100% Yeah
yeah, I I'm just not gonna get that upset about um
You know
Pretending you know, there has to be some actual issue that to make me more upset. Are you a Twitter?
Er, do you spend a lot of time?
I I have a Twitter account and I do tweet from time to time like once a week maybe and
But
I'm mostly view Twitter as a good way to get on the morning and look at it while I'm going to the bathroom
which is the time to look at it about the right amount time and
Not to get too, you know
Detailed. I mean we've already we've already like been twice to the bathroom and I know
Maybe like just a yeah, one more word on this Mike. That's my I was gonna say bread and butter, but that sounds ready
Yeah, that's not where was it? Oh, yeah, so I and I look through Twitter anything
Everybody's got the same people that are always upset about things are still upset about those things
I same people who are getting them. You're wrong about that. Here's my clever retort. Oh, yeah. Well, here's my even clever
They're still all doing that
you know, I don't know where they find the time or the energy to be honest, but it kind of reassures me that whatever our
Meaningless. My life is currently it is not that meaningless that that's what I'm doing all day
That's the good part of Twitter in the past
You've described yourself as a soft libertarian as cynical libertarian. Do you have a preferred?
Modifier I'm always afraid to even bring up libertarian cuz there's so many really like on your case libertarians ready to determine it
You're the wrong kind. You probably are I'll just come out and say you're the wrong kind of like many many tests of
purity, but I
I'm here's the kind of I'm the kind of libertarian who's like when there's a group of people at a party
I'm the only one who is the libertarian so, you know, I don't have to worry about which which stratum of Liberty
I'm on you can robberies
I'm representing all the and and I'm and my my it's always at the basic level of what about the roads?
We wanted to have any roads, you know
that that's kind of level of
Libertarian that III never get really beyond the what are the roads won't people have sex with goats if we don't have a lot
so
You know, I'm fighting the easy fights I'm not
fighting other libertarians about you know, like really fine fine-tuned issues of libertarianism, but won't people have sex
well, they sure will I
In Miami, they heck heck. Yes, that's where I live. So you mean I know I will as soon as it's legal. Yeah
I'm flying you back. Yeah, no same definitely
You sometimes say you're not a satirist. You don't do satire. You're a humorist. What does that distinction mean to you?
Well, I get yeah to me. Okay my joke definition satire humor. That is not funny
That's to say you read it
and you know the person is not
Serious, and it's trying to make you laugh but it never rises to the level of being actually funny
and when I was an English major in college
I read a lot of satire and it was usually like Jonathan Swift, you know
Something like that and you get well that was a joke one joke took them like, you know 8,000 words
And I get why you know if you had a lot of time on your hand and nothing else to do that would be one
Of the more funny things you would you read probably in life, but nowadays. I don't know
There's a lot of other humor out there. So to me, it's just like jokes that just make you laugh
That's humor
Like Anthony Jeselnik is funny though this you know within a minute of watching him
You'll laugh like probably against your will but you'll think you're a horrible person for gaming but you will laugh
What jokes used to be funny to you that aren't funny now
No
Are you another way of asking that was good that I'm allowed to say I think so that was actually say like alright
Have you gotten woke the kid like is there anything where you're like, you know actually?
Very not so much not because I didn't really ever trade particularly in any kind of ethnic humor
Or I guess sexist humor. I mean I've made a
living out of talking about the differences between men and women I have to say I personally like I
read all your books growing up a
Hundred percent of what I believed about the differences between the genders was based on Dave Barry's guide to guys
So thank you for that
It served me well, and I just I don't know if somebody would look at it now and say well I saw an acceptable
But I I don't really think there's anything I would change. I still think that most of us living in the the world
sense or not done so that we know there are certain fundamental differences between
Am I even allowed to say the genders between the sexes? I think if you say all the genders all the yeah and
You know and they're funny the way that
the sexes interact and you know
So I guess maybe somebody would say that's not woke, but I'm not really up for changing
I would say the one okay. Remember there used to be polish jokes. Yes
this is like the 60s 70s and there were millions of them and there were sometimes very funny, but I don't think
Anymore, I would tell a Polish joke, you know unless it was is that because like no one identifies as holy
That's yeah, I wouldn't get a laugh. That's reason. No, I I would just I would think maybe somebody could rightfully find that offensive
So it was like it was a person I knew who was polish
And he and I were good for my best friends are our polish. And then that we we would just laugh and laugh but
Then I would get him to tell a joke about my ethnicity
Which nobody knows so I'm safe you in your new book lessons from Lucy
Which is about your old happy dog you do
Say I believe that Lucy is Jewish. Yeah, so
Well, yes, I do say Lucy. That's one thing. Um, I'm married to a Jewish woman. My daughter's be raised Jewish
Identifies as Jewish but my and my son married a Jewish woman, I've been the guy who held the baby at a bris
You know, so I'm and I go to Temple even though I'm personally an atheist and grace raised Episcopalian
I'm not sure where I'm going with this. Oh, yeah Jews. They're really good about not
Taking themselves too, seriously, they you you can Jews will still tell Jewish jokes, and they're really always funny there inevitably funny
And so I don't know if I'm allowed to went because I'm married to a Jewish woman
tell Jewish jokes I do anyway, but
you
Had a potential run-in with politically incorrect humor with the movie made out of your book big trouble
you tell us the story of
Big trouble. Yeah trouble that it got into. Oh, man
Well, so the plot involves a bomb aboard a nuclear weapon on a plane and but it was otherwise comedy
At least I thought it was funny and it was so sick. I'm out, September 12
2001 the day after 9/11 and so that was the first phone call I got second phone call
you got the morning of 9/11 was the movie people saying the movies not going to come out and
So that it sort of dribbled out
months later and
Didn't really but I don't know if it did well or not, but it that so the boys 9/11 really screwed me over
Nicely not to in any way compare my getting screwed with emails, but one other thing about that that movie
in it
The the Russians are gangsters and I went to Russia a few years ago for the United States State Department
as part of a program where they
With they send they attempt to ignite international incident they sent authors already
You're supposed to increase understanding well, and we see how well that's working
and and so I went there and they said well while you're there you we were gonna we usually have this thing where we have
movie night at the st. Petersburg
Embassy not Embassy, but whatever it's called
they and they have a movie night where they bring in all the Russians who want to come and they show an American movie is
that why don't we show your movie now the previous a
Couple weeks. I've been traveling around doing talks for various groups all around Russia
And and one of the things oh, it is ask them is you know
What do you think our misconceptions are about Russians and I always said two things
You think we're all drunk and you think we're all gangsters
so
Ok, then I comes time for me to present this movie big trouble to a group of Russians
And I thought I'd better quickly review the plot and the first stance is that it has Russians in it
And the second area is they're gangsters. So I had to get up in front of this whole room full of
Russians and say
You my movie does have Russians in it and they are gangsters and there's like I see this these groans
But I said they're they're much smarter than the American gangsters in. So there's that
sort of pro-russian gangster movie you
Had I think if anything is your catchphrase, it's you know, I'm not making this up. We now live in the era of
Fake news did we always live in the era of fake news?
I mean the need to reassure people as far ago, as you know your early columns. He just maybe
Distrust of the media is not a new phenomenon
Well when I started saying I'm not making subs because the things I were talking about were so
Ridiculous and I lie a lot in my column becomes mostly lies
So when those rare occasions when I was gonna say something that really did happen
I would say I'm not making this up as an indication that it's you know
Even though it's ridiculous and it's in my column. It's true. So it wasn't really talking about the you know
Distortions and biases on the part of news media people, although they've always existed
I mean, I've spent my life in the newspaper business, obviously a lot of us are biased and and
We we like to say we're not
But that's not what I was talking about
Florida man, let's talk briefly about Florida man. You did not invent the concept of Florida man you
only occasionally actually are
Florida man in the deepest spiritual sense
What do you make of the rise of the meme of Florida, man? And are you responsible?
No
I'm not responding that a Florida is responsible for you can trace when that happened to the 2000 presidential election when?
Florida was unable to determine
Who had voted for for like several weeks and really is still sure who it voted for
And I think we should just give our electoral votes to like Montana or someplace that can count. Some are more responsible. Yeah, or just
Just not us anymore
Because they lorry up mocked and then there are these
Incidents that happen in Florida and enough of them happened people start noticing that they're having it's not like they're not happening anywhere else
but they are happening a
probably disproportional nimble
Disproportionate number happening in Florida because there's a lot of people in Florida and because a lot people didn't start there
I mean that's my big defense of Florida. Is that most of these people, you know?
Like if you just are seized by a need to get naked and pleasure yourself in a stuffed animal in a Walmart
You're not gonna probably do that in
Zanesville, Ohio, you're gonna go you're gonna go to Miami. You're gonna go to Tampa
You're gonna go down there where it's warm and a welcoming environment for that kind of behavior
so we have a
We're like I said the Ellis Island for weird stupid people they come to us to do their weird stupid things
And you know, that's sort of become our and I think it's a good thing
I hate really first of all, I live there so it's like
Material just shows up on washes up on my doorstep
If you're human writer, there's no better place to live than Florida. But also it's sort of like
It protects the rest of the nation all right, they can all look down on us
If they want to get naked in a Walmart, they know where they can go
And it's it's it's entertainment. It's like a massive forum
every
Morning, DJ in the country is every morning's reading Florida man stories. So we're it's good. What's wrong?
What's bad about it? Has it been good for your original home paper. I mean the Miami on the Florida man beat
Yeah, it is people still want to work at the Miami Herald just because so many weird things happen in the Miami area
So the young people who would otherwise be wise enough to never pick journalism as a career are drawn to it come in
So we have low paid workers
is that your advice to young people considering becoming journalists, like don't do it, but if you must
Florida yeah, you mean they come to at least go someplace interesting
Sorry for the short time before you get bought out or fired cool. Let's talk about your new book lessons from Lucy
It's about your dog. I want to just confess right now. I am NOT a dog. How can you not be a dog person?
Well, okay, you don't have to own a dog be you. I don't really like them. How can you not like dog?
I find it confusing that people want like gross animals and have you ever had a dog if you're underdog I when I was a
Kid, we briefly had a dog. We didn't really bond and what happened tell me that's just a total
Oh, oh are we gonna have it therapy session about my relations?
I uh, it was just a little show me where the dog touched you it's a
Dog, she hung around uneventful E. And then done do you like? Okay. Here's the real quick
Do you like any other animal do you like cats? No, okay. Well, then we can't it's not that I barely like people
Let's that's a whole different thing who likes people to be on
you like your dog you I
Love dogs, dog, Lucy I do
Possibly the only dogs I feel finally about were earnest and zippy they were great to the main dog. And the
Backup dog auxiliary dog. Yes of some of your earlier books
But the book isn't really about dogs, it's really about the fact that you are super old
Yeah, yes. That is what it's about
What does Lucy teach you about being super old?
well
Do you take objecting to super I could just go go? No, I'll go
I'll cop to super I mean, I'm about to turn 72. It's like the next major birthday I face is 80
so how can you not call me old and I was just at my
50th
College reunion and if you don't think you're old because you just have this image of yourself
And you go to your 50th college reunion and all these guys that you used to know
they used to drink bourbon from the shoe of
Our daughter in around you know
bloated and bald and
And sometimes even trying to dance to music from the from our era
Dark times then you feel really alter so I don't I'm not I don't deny in my age, but think okay
So the the premise of the book was simple premise, which is that I'm old Lucy's old. She's she's
She well, I wrote it last year when I was 17 and she was 10. So 70 70 and
And I was like I think everybody who turned 7 he goes through this
phase of like
We don't taking stock and wandering because you can't keep pretending you have forever left when you get to be that age
In and I'm looking at Lucia she's not taking stock. She's fine. Everything's fine for her
She's just happy as she ever was and I'm thing
Like what?
Why can't I do I can't I do that so the book the book is an attempt to figure out
What I could do to be more like my dog, except we're drinking from the toilet
What there we listen again, that's good. I think
triumvirate
In an attempt to figure out how to relate to you as a dog person I ended up
Finding a quote that is from Plato's Republic
Oh wow
As the dogs are the true philosophers because they know friend from foe our dogs the true philosophers know
They wait I was brought because I you don't know Trent Finn from friend from folks if adolf hitler were to walk into our house
My god would love him, you know as much as he let her know. She's Jewish even though she's Jewish
She's like, so maybe that's you know that bad. It's a philosopher
No, I wouldn't go that that far nice nice to people, you know friendly
one of your
resolutions from the book is to spend more time with your
your your lawnmower
drill team
How did Lucy tell you that important? Well, the the idea there was the lawn Rangers
They're called the wand Rangers the world-famous. Zai Rangers
I want to get them there to Arcola, Illinois and broomcorn capital of the world. Okay?
Might as well but and just because you jealous doesn't mean you gotta hate them
I ask you're not a member deeply that way but yeah, I mean the idea there
Dogs are not self-conscious dogs, whatever they do that. They think is fun. They just do it and
People let me among them you get older you think well, I'm too old for that kind of behavior
that sound becoming you know, it's not I look stupid and
Except for wearing really skinny jeans
I don't think there's anything old people shouldn't do if they feel like they want to do them, you know
And yet you are anti AARP. I'm opposed
Well not opposed exactly but they they have this preposterous attitude, which is you're not getting older. Basically. It's like
You know and and and this is like all your mail
That's not from AARP is from catheter companies and yet, you know, we're supposed to think that then you know
They like they say let's get rid of all these these memes about old people can't handle
Technology and old people can't do, you know, you're never too old for anything and I'm like really really are
when I when I go on a book tour, I
You know
People often want to take pictures with their cell
Phones, which is nice
But there is a radical difference between the way people my age take the picture and the way young people take book young people take
picture like this and
People my age go hold it now smile. Okay, no way. It's on Google
No wait
Hold it. Okay smile. No way. It's taking a video. No, you know that and then they hand it to a young person so
Obviously there there are
There's a reason for their stereotypes about older people I live in Miami
where I
See old people drive all the time and they don't drive. Well, they just don't so
I
Can't remember what the question was. Another thing is your memory starts to go. Yeah, but rpr art
yeah, but art keep saying no, but you know, you can do anything like
And I just don't want to get on a plane with the pilot my age
I didn't I want only young young and alert and able to take a picture with a cell phone
Up there Phoebe and yet old people are basically driving our politics, right? Yeah. Yeah, what what's happening there?
Well NAR, it's going to happen to us. Seriously. I don't know. Well, I
started getting Social Security
finally
when I turned 70
Years old and I think it's now the greatest program in the history of great. Good. Excellent
There goes your libertarianism right out the door
Let me hear that like now I'm in the the beating heart of
libertarianism if if you pay into Social Security your entire life and you know
You're never gonna get any anywhere near the money paid in back. It's still wrong to take the money
I'm taking the money like whatever you sow iterance you give I'm
Taking the money, right and if they came along and said we've Dave we've increased Social Security a lot because old people want it
I'd take it probably I wouldn't say no. I can't do that's wrong. I'm a libertarian
I think it's fine to take the money, especially if you paid in I do think the
You know the libertarian moral case here is like you got a you got a fight against future people getting the money
Yeah, we you can really agree on good with that young libertarians
Also, well if there were someone not to get all wonky in some way that younger people could sort by their way out of it
And shift it over in a bit
But then I don't know where I get my money from exactly because of course you just tell these young people
You didn't pay into an account knowing there was no it's a really handy WD in
Iowa it, I don't know that's correct. Yeah, that's a concept that I
Understand why the were the problems are with that. But any honest person who's almost dead and getting money from the government
I'm not gonna change anything
So that's the problem with people like me seems like we've done good work here today hammering out your presidential platform. Well, yeah and
Let me just add that if I were the president United States and I had access to a big chat
That could go anywhere in the world that I wanted it to anytime. I wanted I'd take that baby all over the world
That's what I would mean. I would use I would use the jet I
Would be I have a commitment to jet travel as president. That would be my kind of the cornerstone
Yeah, it wouldn't be less necessarily countries that we need to hammer out agreements would just be nice countries where we know I wouldn't even
Try to hammer anything out when I got there. I just drive around screw up traffic in a motorcade
Maybe go to the beach and then fly home. I would never have any meetings with anybody
I would not meet with foreign leaders about anything they let so you guys are busy do what you want
I'm just going to the beach you'd be kind of a Calvin Coolidge of air trouble. Yeah, just did he do that
Did you just here's a pretty chill president? Yeah, yeah
The very last thing I want to ask you is in
1994 for some reason your interview with reason
centered heavily around the strategic
Helium reserve. Oh
Did it it did I think that dude?
Called it is still an issue. I looked at are we really people are still mad at people for filling balloons with our scarce
Helium. Yeah, just to have fun
I-i've done that so I just as a closing question
Do you still?
Have deep thoughts about the he'll yeah, I would I mean I guess first of all
We need helium country need you can't have a country without helium
I assume yeah, probably so I would go to war for the helium
Yeah, you know we got missiles right who has the helium to be one of the things like we do
Texas has 30% of the world's helium that I shoot fire a couple missiles at Texas if they're not giving it up
Is that what the problem is?
Okay, so we're declaring war on, Texas
Yeah, we need to I mean for the Allium sure, I think we've done good
We want the younger generation to have some heal. Well, we really want them to hear Uncle Dave
Inhale helium and then talk with a funny voice. We don't want to give that up. I mean, that's America, isn't it?
Isn't that why we have America so that we can do that?
And things like it. Yes. Thank you very much. Dave Barry for reason TV. I'm Katherine